thank you
three six
you
uh
detail post
code
left
face
forward march
please be seated
good morning and welcome to central
church my name is michael kitchen i
serve as one of the pastors here and it
is an honor to serve you the community
and the family this morning
today is a bittersweet day
it's bitter because on june 10th 2022
justin
terry was unexpectedly and tragically
taken away from us
we lost a husband a father
a brother a son an uncle
and a community hero
it is sweet because we know the type of
man that justin was
he was the best of the best
he dedicated his entire life to his
friends
to his family into this entire community
justin was also spiritually rooted and
we know now that he is walking the
streets of heaven with god because god
called home one of his warriors to serve
him there
we all had the honor to meet him and
understand the legacy that justin has
left behind
this will be a service where we can
reflect the moments
and the time that we got to spend
together with justin
this will be a time where we can honor
remember
and celebrate the life of justin terry
i would like to read a couple scriptures
to help us focus our time and then pray
and dedicate this time to god
the bible refers to god in many ways
particularly as a good shepherd
and that he promises to comfort all
those who mourn
god tells us that wherever two or more
gathered in his name he is here
let us listen to what god is saying to
us as we read his word and reflect on
the promises that are the basis for our
hope today
psalm
the lord is my shepherd
i shall not be in want
he makes me lie down in green pastures
he leads me beside quiet waters
he restores my soul
he guides me in paths of righteousness
for his name's sake
even though i walk through the valley of
the shadow of death i will fear no evil
for you are with me your rod and your
staff there comfort me you prepare a
table before me in the presence of my
enemies
you anoint my head with oil my cup
overflows
surely goodness and mercy will follow me
all the days of my life and i will dwell
in the house of the lord forever
john 14 1-6
do not let your hearts be troubled
trusting god
trust also in me
in my father's house there are many
rooms if there were not so i would have
told you i am going there to prepare a
place for you
and if i go and prepare a place for you
i will come back and take you with me so
that you will also be where i am
you know the way to this place where i
am going
i am the way
the truth and the life
no one comes to the father except
through me
john 11 25 26
i am the resurrection
and the life the one who believes in me
will live
even though they die
and whoever lives by believing in me
will never die
justin is experiencing the fullness of
all these verses verses now
please join me in prayer
heavenly father lord we come to you
right now with heavy hearts
lord we thank you that we don't have to
experience these times alone
not only have you promised to come along
beside us
to be our shepherd and to comfort us but
you have also blessed us with friends
family and the benefits of drawing
strength from one another
so god we pray that you will hold us in
your powerful caring hands during this
time
and be glorified in our lives
grant us comfort so that we may comfort
others who are also hurting
we thank you god for justin
we thank you for the opportunity to have
known him in this life we thank you for
the legacy and the life that he has left
behind
i pray for everyone gathered here today
with grieving hearts
help them release their tears if they
need to
as they say goodbyes for now
and remind them that they are the hope
in the midst of the pain
we pray all these things in the name of
the father
the son
and the holy spirit
amen
at this time we would like to have
speakers present that the family has
prepared for and first is retired senior
inspector of the united states marshal
services felix serrano and lvmpd
sergeant nick madsen
on behalf of my squad in the department
i would like to thank everyone for
coming out um justin is a remarkable
human being which you're going to hear
repeatedly today
and he would be touched that everyone
came out to honor him uh before felix
and i read what we would like to share
about justin i would like to also read
the obituary
it's in the program but i'm going to
subject you to this voice a little
longer anyways
justin michael terry was taken from this
life the morning of june 10th 2022
husband to stacy father to sean and
jacob son to joyce and harold brother to
lisa and joshua
uncle to jordan payton sebastian and
ashter
brother-in-law to danielle james and
molina son-in-law to erlinda and arthur
dog dad to camper
and friend to so many justin will be
forever missed by everyone who had the
privilege of knowing him
more than just an amazing husband to
stacy he was her favorite person in the
world
more than just a brother he was joshua's
twin and best friend
more than just an uncle he was a role
model
anyone who knew justin will say that it
was nothing less than a privilege and a
joy to have to have had him touch their
lives
justin was born in medford oregon but
raised in southern california since
grade school he had a deep connection
with saint andrews abbey in vallieremo
california
his first job at this benedictine
monastery in the high desert
he graduated from little rock high
school where he made lifelong friends
that he kept to this day
after getting his degree in criminal
justice he moved to nevada and joined
the las vegas metropolitan police
department in 2001.
as a detective justin was assigned to
the homicide sex crimes bureau
sexual assault and abuse section
prior to that he was assigned to the
sexual sexual offender apprehension
detail or soap for seven years on the
task force but closer to 12 overall
he was widely regarded as an expert in
the field and he was a sworn task force
officer with the u.s marshals service
justin was a leader in the cops on top
memorial annual hike in which officers
family and friends climbed to the peaks
of the tallest mountains across the
country to remember fallen police
officers
he also started the enduro program at
southeast area command making it
possible for officers to ride dual sport
motorcycles into hard to reach locations
to service the homeless population
justin was the best of all of us he
dedicated his life to family friends and
to service
justin loved life whether that was
camping under the stars barbecuing with
family or enjoying his home with his
beloved wife
he loved spending time with family and
friends being outdoors and exploring
remote places off the beaten path
he was a selfless individual who always
put others before himself
justin had a natural presence about him
that inspired you to be better he leaves
a legacy for everyone to aspire to
he will always be an example of love
integrity and selflessness for everyone
who knew him to follow
while no longer physically with us we
know that he will always be close to us
in spirit he will live forever in our
hearts
before i
give my thoughts on justin i would like
to introduce someone very important to
him
those of us in law enforcement know that
if we're lucky we
have a lot of great partners throughout
the years but those of us who are truly
lucky know that we have that one partner
that one who
we become so close with that people
think that we're the same person because
they never hear our names unless one is
immediately followed by the other
and because justin was who he was he
touched lots of people that way but we
all know his one true partner was felix
serrano who was recently retired from
the u.s marshals service
good morning
like i said i'm felix and uh just before
warning i'm gonna be a hot mess
so here we go
and i'm also going blind it's okay
um
during the last 15 years of my career i
always saw the sex offender program for
the district of nevada i met justin
terry in 2010 when he was a brand new
detective to the lvmpd sex offender
apprehension program and i was new to my
position
in 2014 justin was sworn in as a special
deputy united states marshal and was
assigned to the sex offender predator
apprehension team this was a
multi-agency task force whose mission
was to investigate unregistered sex
offenders
for the district of nevada
justin was a great police officer a
great detective a great man but overall
a great human being
when i first met justin i knew we would
get along what i did not know was the
great partnership and friendship i would
have over the next 11 plus years
all of us have one or two justin terry
stories
i was fortunate enough to have many
one of my most memorable justin stories
was when he invited me to one of his
annual trips to boundary peak
as we all know justin would like to hike
the tallest peak in nevada once a year
to honor the fallen officers for that
year
he had done this for several years i
agreed to go but later realized i should
have asked more questions
my fault
however justin did not provide any
information
his fault
the day of the trip we arrived at the
campsite and i'm going to fast forward
through a lot of this
set up camp and we're soon joined by
other hikers
people that he knew throughout the state
everyone started talking about what they
did to prepare for this trip
justin told us he did his usual workout
and if everybody knows justin he was a
beast in the gym
he did add that justin added that he
that he also did extra stuff to prepare
he must have seen the confusion in my
face because i looked up at him and he
said don't worry you'll be fine
and we go on
one by one everybody said what they had
done to prepare
when it was my turn as bold as i could
i could be i said i did nothing
justin invited me and i came
someone in the in the group said it's
okay if you don't make it the first time
i looked at justin again but in true
justin's style he once again just said
you'll be fine don't worry about it
when the morning of the hike was upon us
we were all getting our gear together
and justin tells me hey bro
there might be some hands-on
but did not explain what hands-on meant
so we move on as we traveled along i
began to fall behind in the group which
was well ahead of us i told justin go
ahead i would catch up
justin would have none of that
he just kept pushing me along says we're
in no rush as we got closer to the peak
i quickly found out what hands-on meant
for those of you that did not know
justin he was part billy goat
he was standing around taking pictures
just enjoying the scenery
and telling me to do the same i didn't
want to look anywhere else but accept my
next step
eventually we came up on this boulder
justin made it around without any issue
remember billy goat
and i on the other hand not so much
as i wrapped myself around the boulder
to get around it started to move
as i looked up there was the rest of the
mountain above me
a very steep drop behind me
then i looked at justin not only was he
still taking pictures but he looked at
me and said you're doing great
come on
we finally made it to the top of the
peak where there were high fives and
pictures taken it was a nice
accomplishment for the group and of
course a nice accomplishment for me
personally
as i was standing up by myself to take
all of it in
justin came over and asked hey what's up
so i asked him no one is coming for us
he said no
in true just in fashion and only the way
justin can do it he said don't worry
gravity will handle this part
this story always reminded me how justin
always had my back it would never let me
fail
justin was the very best of us he made
all of us better for knowing him most
people could only be lucky to meet a
justin once maybe twice in their entire
lifetime
sorry
i had the honor approved to call justin
my friend
today as we lay to later arrest a great
man and i like mentioned earlier an
outstanding human being we are all sad
but i know justin would not want us to
be he would want us to keep moving
forward he would want us to continue
to live our lives to the max and he
would want us to remember that we will
be fine
to justice family please know that just
like justin always had my back i will
always have yours whatever you need
whenever you need me never hesitate to
call
thank you for giving me this great honor
today god bless all of
you thank
i was going to try to speak without the
help of notes but i'm going to be
a true hot mess not just say i am like
felix claimed he was going to be
i could speak for hours about what made
justin terry
the greatest kindest most genuinely good
human being i have ever met
and as we were preparing for this so
many of us said it's funny how most of
our justin stories have nothing to do
with police work or police stories we
have plenty of those but
when you think of justin that's not
nearly the first thing you think of
out of respect for all of your ears i'll
try to keep it under an hour
for the last year and a half i had the
privilege of having justin work on my
squad but what i'm always going to
cherish is that i have been his friend
for almost 21 years
justin and i entered the metro academy
within about six weeks of each other
back in 2001 and then in 2002 we both
landed on graveyard at the old southeast
area command
we were not on the same squad but we
shared three nights a week on two very
junior squads and
everyone in this room will understand
that
we spent those years the same way every
great your graveyard officer does
learning the job and finding our way
together
but even then it was obvious that justin
was special even amongst all of us
while the rest of us young first
two-year cops were very impressed by our
own greatness
running around with our chests puffed
out strutting for all the world to see
to hide how scared we all were
justin never got too high he never got
too low
he was humble which will not surprise
anyone here and he just did his job and
he did it very very well
after graveyard i got to be justin's
partner in cop for a year that's
community policing
that was the year i really learned what
makes him such a special person
he was always kind he was always
compassionate he was always generous and
he was always just impossibly good you
would search for the flaws and you would
become so frustrated when you could not
find one
he always had a smile
and he remained the most humble among us
despite the fact that he was the most
brilliant among us
and that as i learned to the detriment
of my ego he was also the most
physically strong human being i've ever
met in my life
he always was the tall skinny lanky guy
in his uniform and i made the mistake of
taking him up on an offer to work out
with him one time and that lasted about
three minutes and i decided my ego did
not need that anymore
in the cop job we dealt with community
groups apartment managers the county
seamart liaisons
everywhere we went everyone fell in love
with justin
when we would show up as a group the
first thing out of everyone's mouth
where's justin
and you couldn't be upset about it
because you understood every day when
you came to work you wanted to see
justin
i also learned that year that there is
not a more dedicated father on the earth
whenever he talked about sean and jakey
back in those days i'm sorry jacob but
you were jakey to us back then
whenever he talked about sean and jakey
he would light up in a way that i had
never seen before and i still don't
think i've seen to this day
after cop we lost touch took separate
career paths that happens in this job we
all know that we lose touch with people
we care about
but we all wound up in the old crimes
against youth and family which is the
precursor to homicide sex crimes a few
years later
being in the same bureau we would run
into each other in the hallways and
break rooms
and this is where i learned the other
secret about justin that i will always
cherish
justin terry is the best hugger in the
history of the world there is no one on
earth that hugs like that man does
at that time in my life i was not much
of a hugger especially with people who
were not immediate family unless i saw
justin
if i saw justin three times
five times eight times within a ten
minute span
you can bet i was going to get a hug
every time and he may have been annoyed
with it but he never showed it he always
just smiled and shrugged his shoulders
but when he hugged you the warmth and
the compassion and the strength that are
his essence would just flow out of him
and
it was an amazing feeling you could feel
the love that made justin such a special
person
about a year and a half ago
ten years of me begging and whining and
pleading finally paid off and i
convinced him to come work with me and
saj
within days he made his typical impact
my newer detectives fell in love with
him they
did and do look up to him as a big
brother as i knew they would which is
part of why i wanted him there
we work off-site with cps and cac
personnel they all fell for his charms
immediately as well
he's the perfect mentor to younger
detectives and he approached every day
with his typical smile and the patience
of a saint he treated everyone kindly
whether they were a victim or a suspect
or anyone in between
we had a little bit of another ego hit
my other detectives and i at the office
because he became so beloved that when
people needed furniture moved in the
office
even if he was not there we would be
told no no we're going to wait for
justin
and so we learned we don't even ask
anymore we'll just wait for as
bobby named him the stallion to show up
and take care of that
the last time i spoke to justin
i was getting ready to leave for the
night and he was sitting at his desk
and he was beaming as he talked to me
about jacob's recent graduation and
stacy's upcoming promotion
he told me he was staying late so he
could be there when stacey got off work
so he could help her plan her move into
her new office downtown
i was leaning in my doorway or in his
doorway i'm sorry watching the goodness
shine off of this man
and i just shook my head and all i could
say to him is you are just the best dude
he just gave me his cheapest sheepish
justin smile in the ah wave of his hand
because he knew i was right but it was
embarrassing him
what i actually meant when i told him
you were such a great dude and what i
wish i had said
in that moment and thousands of moments
before then
is justin i love you so much
never in 21 years did i tell him that i
love him as if he is my own brother
and that my life is immeasurably richer
for knowing him
in my heart i know that justin has
always known how much i love him and how
much we all love him
but i will always regret not making him
listen to me say it to his face
i would love to have seen him turn red
and smirk that little justin smirk when
he looked down
the great jackie robinson once said a
life is not important except in how it
impacts other lives
justin michael terry left an indelible
mark on every life that he touched
anyone who knew him for more than a few
minutes was given hope that people like
him actually exist
in our world especially it is so easy to
become jaded about other people and
about humanity and justin not only did
not become jaded
he gave you hope that people like him
are actually out there
he inspired all of us to strive to be
the kind of human being he is
stacy and camper even though camper's
not here today
sean jake helen joyce
lisa josh and danielle
there are just not enough words to
sufficiently thank you for sharing this
amazing man with us all these years
we are all so grateful to have had him
and now to have all of you in our lives
and i told joyce but i didn't get to
tell the rest of you that you all had
inherited a whole bunch of brothers and
sisters that you probably never wanted
to my squad
i challenge you to carry justin with you
for the rest of your lives
he was very proud of you all he was
proud of the work you did as a team
and i would want you as i do to ask
yourself in the toughest toughest
moments you face
what would justin do here
to newer cops and detectives i would
urge you to take what you've heard here
about what made this man so special the
compassion the integrity the patience
the goodness
and carry those lessons with you moving
forward in your career and in your life
to everyone else who hears this i would
beg you to tell the people you love how
you feel about them tell them directly
and tell them often
don't have regrets that you never said
what you should have said when you had
the chance
that is the best way i know to keep
justin's spirit alive and to honor all
that he means to us
justin my friend
i love you and i will keep you with me
always
and i would just like to tell you one
last time
thank you
thank you felix and nick for those kind
words and those memories that you shared
at this time we'd like to welcome up las
vegas metropolitan police department
sheriff joe lombardo
well i want to start off by saying nick
and felix
thank you for your words they were
fantastic you weren't a hot mess at all
so that's good
well good morning everyone
i want to start by extending my
condolences and my gratitude to the
terry family
detective justin terry chose a career of
sacrifice and service
and you supported him every step of the
way
because of your support detective terry
made a huge impact on the lives of our
citizens
his passion and his focus most of his
career was on protecting vulnerable
children
it's not an easy assignment it takes a
special person a special detective
to work these cases but everyone knew
justin would tell you
he was above all
a patient man
the men and women in his unit marveled
at how he spent his hours building
rapport with a suspect too much time so
they thought
but then he would walk out of the
interview room shrug
and say yeah but i just got a confession
everyone always knew which justin they
were going to get because there was only
one justin
person after person would tell you he
was always smiling always patient
and like to end the conversations with
his trademark two thumbs up
one of the detectives terry's passions
one of detective terry's passions
was supporting and remembering fallen
officers through memorial hikes during
one of those hikes he an older gentleman
was having was that you felix the older
gentleman
no
an older gentleman was having difficulty
keeping up while everyone else climbed
on justin stayed behind to help the man
make it to the peak i think it was you
you got gray in your goatee
i share these stories with you because
detective justin terry was one of the
best
he made this department better and he
made our community better
this profession is like no other
i can it can take a toll on officers as
they see
and hear things no one should have to
experience
yet justin never let
it change him from the moment he entered
the sports
21 years ago
until the day he said goodbye he was the
same man
stacy
i want you to know how indebted this
community is to your husband
sean and jacob
not many sons can say they had a father
like yours remember you are not alone
you are part of our law enforcement
family forever
a lot of times we say that in jest and i
will build on that
reference what nick said
you are part of the family forever
and you need to you need to always
remember that
bless detective justin terry and god
bless his family
thank you very much
thank you sheriff lombardo for those
kind words your amazing leadership
through this
trying times
and always being there for the families
at this time i'd like to introduce and
welcome up father sean weeks
this morning when i
arrived to justin's house with the rest
of the family
stacy's dad asked me if i was the
department chaplain
i'm not the department chaplain
for 24 years
any time i've had to be at one of these
services
i have been the department chaplain
having done the work
for a lot of agencies in the state of
oregon
in los angeles
but today
i'm here as friend
it's been 20 years
since i've been in the presence of
justin
i was one of the benedictine monks
that 28 years ago
the terry family would come into my life
justin and joshua
would i would create a really special
connection to
and
justin is everything
28 years ago
as a young high school student
was already budding to be
all the great things we've heard
said about him so far
i got a phone call
from one of the monks father carlos
on the day
or justin passed
and he knew
i haven't had much connection with the
monastery either
but he knew that justin was
very close to my heart and he wanted me
to know
and he wanted me to pray
and so i reached out i sent a simple
i'm praying for you condolence to joshua
and then
24 hours later i would get a message
from joshua
just thanking me for reaching out
telling me that
they have often spent time remembering
the times we had spent together
he wanted me to know that justin loved
me
and i wept
i felt guilty
and then a couple days later
and i offered masses for the family
joyce you'll get a
mass card here shortly
joshua will call me again next time on
the phone
and we would both apologize for falling
out of each other's lives
i told him don't do that to yourself
we
spent some time doing a little small
talk and
and then josh were getting a little
choked up
he asked me if i could come
and be present
and say a funeral mass for his brother
and so i'm here
just since i've arrived
yesterday
it's been story after story
memory after memory
proving
that love doesn't age out
i'd like to share with you gospel
passage from the gospel of saint matthew
chapter seven first five verses
jesus said to his disciples stop judging
that you may not be judged
for as you judge so will you be judged
and the measure with which you measure
will be measured out to you
why do you notice the splinter in your
brother's eye
but not perceive the wooden beam
in your own eye
how can you say to your brother let me
remove that splinter from your eye while
the wooden beam is in your eye
you hypocrite
remove the wooden beam
from your eye first
then you will see clearly
to remove the splinter
from your brother's eye
i chose that gospel passage this morning
because
justin
was a self-reflective person
we are here talking about his greatness
but he was well aware of his weakness
and it was because he was aware of his
weakness
that he could look to the one in front
of him
and look to them
with understanding
with the desire to build up
rather than to tear down
see every one of us has spoken into this
world one time by god
our creator spoken one time never to be
repeated
ever but he's got an identical twin
but they're very different
we were spoken into this world to be
gift
and to walk in this life
in such a way as to walk as to return
to the father
at the monastery
where i met
justin
you drive up to the hill and there's a
sign
no hunting
except for peace
and i know there's a lot of hearts
seeking peace and hunting for peace
today
when i heard of justin's passing
it
made a big old piercing wound
in my heart
and i worried for his family
on justin's prayer card you'll see the
words
of john gospel of john chapter 1
verse 50.
light
has come into this world
in darkness
has not overcome it
the loss of justin
is intense
but that light jesus christ who has come
into this world
and for whom
and with whom
justin was baptized
and loved and was loved by
is that light
and love
this room is not filled with darkness
this room has sadness
but not darkness
and love
is bigger than death
love
conquered death
so as we sit there and we find ourselves
just
what do we do with this
there's a lot of us that want to take
everything we can out of this life
one thing i've been i've been reflecting
on all night
what made justin special
he didn't approach this life to take
something from it
he approached this life
pouring himself into it
and he did so out of love
and we need to remember
that
the one who loved him
even more than i do or
his closest
family and friends do
has a sacred heart
and all the pain the intensity of the
pain will subside
it will not go away
so we continue walking
because
justin my friend
we will meet again
and for that
my heart finds some healing
thank you father weeks
and at this time if we could have the
representatives from the terry family
come up to share some words please
so
justin was my brother
i'm speaking for both my brother and i
and my family
so you hear a lot of people talking
about what a
dedicated officer justin was
about all the good service he did
he loved his job
it was all he ever wanted to do
for him it was a vocation
a calling
but aside from all that
justin was everything to his family
he was juicy or juice man
in light-hearted moments
but only to family and close friends
he was my brother
but so often he was my rock
no matter where i was in the world
i knew that justin was there for me
as he was for so many
when i was abroad and had to come back
to the states to deal with a difficult
situation in dc
justin flew across the country to meet
me there
and stayed just for moral support just
to be there with me
he's done that more than once
he was always there for me
and everyone in our family
whether it was to help with something
lend a sympathetic ear
provide a strong shoulder or just for a
hug
because justin's hugs were magic
he has been especially important in my
life as a role model for my two sons
his nephew sebastian and asher
i always tell them that i'm raising them
to be good men
good men like their uncle justin and
uncle joshua
because they could have no better role
models
one of the last times i saw justin in
person
he took me aside just to tell me how
proud he was of me
and the job i was doing raising these
young gentlemen
even though he's my little brother
that meant so much to me
but i know that it's not just me
they are who they are
and my brothers and i are who we are
because of family
we have always recognized
how lucky we are
to have the family we have
justin and joshua had a connection
that few people on this earth will ever
experience
while very different
they're also the same in in many ways
the best ways
they often share the same thoughts
i can't tell you how many times they
showed up to something wearing the same
thing
and when they were little
they had their own language before they
learned to speak
justin had a presence about him
that not only commanded respect
but imparted respect
i dare anyone to find a single person
who could say anything bad about justin
even with someone he had a disagreement
with that person would still say that
justin was a good man
he could just de-escalate any situation
just with his natural demeanor
to every officer who knew justin i will
say this
justin's watched
in the physical world over his sons sean
and jacob has ended
now it's up to you to help fill that
role
keep watch over these boys
and be there in the way that their
father cannot
and the same for stacy
justin was so lucky to have found his
other half
and even though their time together was
shorter than it should have been
they both brought each other so much joy
i'm so happy
that my brother got to experience that
kind of love in his life
which was cut way too short
so while physically departed
justin will remain with us in so many
ways
quiet nights under the stars
walking on a trail
hearing a familiar song
visiting a special place
justin will be with us
and even in this unbearable grief
i can close my eyes
and feel justin's hug
and hear his voice
say that it's gonna be okay
at first i wasn't not sure if i could
even stand up here or even make it up
here
but i think with this podium and
my family and and god
i'll be able to say a few words
justin was my son
a best friend
another best friend
family of best friends
he was humble
he was my hero
i told him once after we had set and
talked for a few minutes we shared our
thoughts for the day
and i told him
you're my hero
and justin in his way said dad just
doing my job just doing my job
well
when justin did his job he did it like
he lived his life
honesty
and
and integrity
and again
what everybody says
if you ever got a justin hug
you know y'all done being hugged
david no no little little yeah no man
you got a hug
i was talking with his nephews
sebastian and asher
and i don't know who was consoling who
at that time
and i said you know guys you know we
just got to think about
the good times the happy times that we
had with your uncle justin
and they both looked up and they said
but grandpa there were no other times
there were no bad times no unhappy times
all we had was good times with uncle
justin
and so we all i know his squad members
fellow officers
you've had good times
with justin
cherish those times
and never forget him
and thank you all
the family would like sean and jake to
please come up to the podium
thank you everybody for all of the
absolutely kind words and stories that
you all have shared
it just completely reflects on the type
of person that my dad was
i'm sean justin's oldest son and this is
my brother jacob
i'll have to start off with some dad
advice
pardon the cell phone notes as my dad
was a boy scout he told me always to be
prepared
well
let's say the notes didn't make it but i
thought of my dad and i took a picture
of the notes and here they are
so
as i can't really think straight right
now i'm gonna probably be reading off of
this more often than not
for those of you that know me
i really wanted to say something funny
to make you all laugh and smile
but i really wanted to say this from the
heart
first of all wow
the outreach
everything
that everyone has done for
my dad and our family has been nothing
short of incredible
however i'm not sure this is what my dad
would have wanted
because he hated being the center of
attention
sorry dad you're gonna have to deal with
it because you were loved by so many
just seeing and knowing how many people
he touched in some way or another is
absolutely amazing
he truly was the best of us
and
as i've been told a hundred times over
by all of you
if you spent more than two minutes with
him you knew how amazing of a person he
was
recently i heard something of
that
someone said online
i don't know whether or not it's true
but knowing my dad i believe it to be
true
someone out there
said that he was the most kind and
polite police officer to have ever
arrested him
as crazy as that sounds you and i all
know that that is probably true
to be completely honest i didn't know
what to say or right
my first thought
was that i needed to ask dad for some
help
he was the most well-spoken person
that i have ever known
and i'm not just saying that because i'm
biased
he deeply understood the most powerful
thing a person has is their words
trust me i can go on for hours telling
you all how great he was
but i will say that i cannot be more
thankful to have had him as a dad
i owe him everything for who i am today
i'm thankful that he was able to see me
grow up
and he was able to see my brother
recently graduate
i'm thankful that he was able to guide
me through a few years of adult life to
give me some good experience
to help
share to my brother
because i promised my dad
that i would care for him if anything
ever happened
my dad barely ever asked for help
and he always wanted to help others
so i'll try and leave you all with some
of the advice that he gave me
he knew and he understood his morality
her
mortality both as well
it's a sad thing to think about but it
cannot be more true especially in this
line of work
tomorrow is never promised
life is too short to be upset
with those that
always tell them that you love them
and how you feel
there is always the chance that you may
never see them walk through that door
again
we knew he loved us and that he was
proud of us
and we were of him as well
because we said it
nothing was left unsaid
and we are extremely lucky to have peace
with that
there are others who cannot say the same
i will not miss anything more than those
big strong hugs that he gave when i said
i'll see you later
thank you
i just wanted to thank everyone for
coming out today in remembrance of my
dad
um
it's just amazing to see
all the lives that he has touched
yesterday was a very
rough day because yesterday was father's
day it was the first one with
our dad there
we had never imagined something like
that
but
there's
no words to describe how thankful i am
and how thankful we are for
all the time we got to spend with him
and all the father's days
we couldn't have asked for a
better dad to raise us to
who we are today
and who we will become
and we're so thankful we were able to
call him our dad
and
i know he hated
being the center of attention he's
probably a little mad right now
but
in my opinion he
deserves all the attention in the world
because he was the best of all of us
and
like sean said not i'm not biased
but he was the greatest man i have ever
met
he was the most selfless humble and
caring human being
and
something him and i would always do is
go to the movies
and you know there's a lot of
superhero movies
and even after
watching all those superheroes on the
big screen and everything
there was always
one hero i looked up to
and that was it
he was just the best person i could ever
look up to
he always has been and always will be my
hero
and
i found this quote i wrote it down in my
english notebook and
found it the other day actually my
girlfriend found it the other day
and came across it
and i forgot where i found it but i
wanted to share it that
it doesn't get easy
i want everyone to remember that
thank you
i would like to thank all the speakers
that presented this morning
thank you for your hearts thank you for
your memories of justin
at this time the family would like to
share a video with you afterwards the
honor guard will then begin their
ceremonies
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
so
[Music]
my
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
over there
officers
you